the US National Library of Medicine
presents mercury and our health a short
film by the Environmental Health student
portal
hi mom thanks again for the sushi I'll
watch a little bit of TV while I'm
eating and then I'm gonna go do my
homework okay but don't watch it for too
long
this is Kate from food science for
consumers today's episode is about
mercury in seafood there may be too much
mercury in the seafood you are eating
watts to find out a learn how to protect
your health mercury and seafood I wonder
is the Sochi seafood it sure is but
don't be alarmed before you learn more
mom the TV characters are coming to life
again that's nice dear do you know what
mercury is no but it sounds like it's
something bad
mercury is a natural metal that's found
in the air water and soil what do you
mean by natural natural means it's a
part of the environment and is not made
by humans it also exists in the Earth's
crust wait what do you mean by crust
oh the crust is the outermost rocky
layer of the planet whoa cool where are
we we are on the periodic table of
elements you see we can find mercury on
this table of elements by looking over
its chemical symbol what's the chemical
symbol of mercury
the chemical symbol of mercury is Hg
this is how we can find it on the
periodic table remember that we can find
mercury in the environment in several
forms sometimes atoms of mercury exist
alone not connected with other elements
this form of mercury is called metallic
or elemental people also call this kind
of mercury Quicksilver or liquid mercury
because it's a shiny silver liquid that
can evaporate to an invisible gas oh I
see at other times atoms of mercury
combine with other elements and create
compounds or chemical mixtures we may
encounter mercury in different
situations depending on what form it is
in different forms of mercury also
affect our health differently
how can mercury affect my health
if enough mercury gets into your body it
could really make you sick oh I don't
like being sick
of course you don't luckily if you live
in the u.s. there are not that many ways
for you to have contact with a lot of
mercury but what exactly does mercury do
well that depends depends on what
several things like how much mercury
gets into your body the form of mercury
that gets into your body how the mercury
gets into your body and how long you're
exposed to mercury
high levels of mercury in the body can
really hurt many body systems especially
the brain and kidneys the brain how does
it hurt the brain these are some of the
symptoms of brain damage from mercury
poisoning tremors or trembling is
shaking and not being able to stop
walking impairments or having difficulty
walking speech impairments or having
difficulty forming clear words changes
in vision or hearing memory loss loss of
appetite or not feeling hungry feeling
irritated and psychosis or losing touch
with reality like seeing or hearing
things that are not there I don't like
it can it do this to anyone yes
mercury poisoning could happen to anyone
but it is especially damaging to
children and unborn babies but I'm a
child why is it especially bad for
children because their nervous systems
are still developing the younger the
child is the more sensitive he or she is
to mercury you are more sensitive than
an adult but young children and babies
are even more sensitive than you are but
you said that there are not that many
ways for me to have contact with a lot
of mercury I guess that's the good news
but then you also said that mercury is a
natural part of the earth this makes the
earth a dangerous place
mercury can only hurt us if we come in
contact with it touch it
breathe it and swallow it mercury in the
Earth's crust is hidden in the rocks so
the amount of mercury that's normally
found in the environment is very very
small and will not hurt us
that's good to hear yes unfortunately
people do things that make mercury come
out where we can come in contact with it
what do you mean people do things that
make mercury come out let me give you an
example
I mentioned that mercury is found in
many rocks including coal people burn
coal for energy unfortunately when we
burn coal we release it's mercury into
the air and the environment oh I see
mercury also has many properties that
people find useful so we use it in
commercial products what kinds of
properties for example pure or elemental
mercury conducts electricity it also
combines with other metals into
combinations that have many uses other
forms of mercury kill bacteria so we use
mercury in some commercial products I'm
not sure I like this we use mercury in
products yes but less than we used to
people have known about the helpful
useful characteristics of mercury for a
long time but the knowledge about it's
dangerous to human health is more recent
in the past people often used mercury in
medicines because of its bacteria
killing properties oh that's ironic but
in general now that we know that mercury
can be dangerous we look for
alternatives to it whenever we can so
what products have mercury let me give
you some examples glass thermometers
electrical switches
fluorescent lightbulbs dental fillings
vaccine preservatives some medical
equipment some batteries and old paints
boy there's mercury in thermometers in
some glass thermometers he makes mercury
expand or grow and this property of
mercury was used in mercury-in-glass
thermometers these thermometers were
used for centuries but now that we know
that mercury can be dangerous
they've become rare I've seen them in
pictures inside books that's right
but the thermometer your parents used to
take your temperature probably looks
like this and uses an electronic
temperature sensor that people get hurt
a lot by all those old glass
thermometers
remember mercury is dangerous to us only
when we touch it breathe it or swallow
it we cannot touch breathe or swallow
mercury inside a thermometer the danger
happens when someone accidentally breaks
the thermometer Oh glass things are easy
to break what happened then
well the shiny silver elemental mercury
would spill and collect into silver
balls beautiful but dangerous someone
cleaning up the spill could accidentally
touch it
look how dangerous that is
there was also a risk of breathing it
because liquid elemental mercury
evaporated into invisible gas what about
batteries
for a long time companies around the
world used mercury to make many kinds of
batteries they did it because mercury
prevented the build-up of hydrogen gas
in batteries which can cause the battery
to bulge and leak since the 1980s the
use of mercury in batteries in the US
has been going down what about the
batteries in my TV remote
do they have mercury most batteries made
in the US today do not have mercury in
them with few exceptions your typical
double-a or triple-a batteries for your
remote control do not have mercury in
them that's good but which batteries
have it then one of the exceptions is
button cell batteries these are very
small batteries that look like coins or
buttons and are used in small portable
electronic devices like wristwatches Oh
my watch has a battery like that should
I get rid of it
remember mercury can only hurt you if
you touch it breathe it or swallow it
you aren't touching the mercury because
it's inside the battery inside the watch
but you said dental fillings have
mercury those definitely go inside our
bodies have you ever heard of silver
fillings they're called silver because
of their silver color but they are
actually an amalgam or blend of metallic
mercury silver and some other metals
very small amounts of mercury are slowly
released from the blend over time for
example while you chew see I knew it
but you have to remember that the amount
makes a big difference in whether
something is dangerous or not from what
we know right now amalgam dental
fillings do not harm people's health I
don't get it
it sounds like a lot of these products
that have mercury in them keep it hidden
or put in very small amounts so does
this mean that we have nothing to worry
about not really remember a lot of the
products I mentioned eventually break or
become useless so we'll need to get rid
of them at some point you mean throw
them in the trash that's
it's not that simple Oh gross it stinks
if we simply dump trash that has mercury
in it into the environment it will go
into our soil and water and build up
there so what are we supposed to do with
the mercury containing products we can't
keep the broken stuff forever
we have special ways to get rid of
mercury waste many cities and towns now
have hazardous household waste
facilities or events but many products
that have mercury still end up in
landfills or incinerators that burn
trash which means mercury is eventually
released into the environment and often
ends up in rivers and oceans which is
really bad why is it so bad we don't
drink water directly from rivers and
oceans we clean it before it gets into
our faucets I learned about that at
school but fish don't get it clean for
them in the United States the most
common way to be exposed to mercury is
by eating fish or shellfish that have
high levels of mercury come let me show
you let's take a closer look at the
environment
when people burn coal for energy the
mercury in the coal rocks is released
into our environment see look how the
mercury is getting into the environment
once the mercury is in the environment
it eventually gets into the soil and
water but how exactly does it get into
fish let's take a closer look at the
contaminated water
once mercury is in the water some
microorganisms converted into a very
toxic form of mercury called methyl
mercury which looks like this then the
methyl mercury gets into fish by going
up the food chain through a process
called biomagnification first some tiny
aquatic plants and animals absorb the
methyl mercury that's in the water fish
and other animals feed on these teeny
aquatic plants and animals so the methyl
mercury gets passed on to them next
bigger fish eat the smaller fish and
absorb the methyl mercury and so on and
so forth the higher up the food chain we
go the more mercury of fish accumulates
yuck look at all that methyl mercury in
the tile fish sharks and swordfish the
longer these fish have been alive the
more time they've had to eat other fish
and the more methyl mercury they have in
their bodies bigger older fish that eat
other fish usually have the highest
levels of mercury is it bad for people
well if people eat a lot of seafood
that's high in mercury this can be bad
remember I've said before that mercury
is especially bad for babies and unborn
children
that's why pregnant women have to be
careful about how much mercury
containing fish they eat oh no my Sochi
are the fashion Sochi high up in the
food chain do they accumulate a lot of
mercury should I stop eating fish there
are many benefits to eating fish also
your mom use salmon and shrimp to make
that sushi these usually have lower
levels of mercury if you want to learn
more about being safe while eating
seafood click on the links that are on
our page but how we're inside a video
inside a TV it's ok to stop the video or
finish watching and then come back I'm
also posting these links on the webpage
on our video so you can read more about
mercury Wow I've learned a lot today
what did you learn I learned that
mercury is a natural metal people used
to use it in many products but now they
use it less and less most
products we use at home are safe for us
still much mercury ends up in the water
and accumulates in fish and that's bad
for fish and bad for us that's right is
there anything else I should know some
cosmetic creams imported from other
countries could have mercury at levels
much higher than allowed for creams
manufactured in the US also some
alternative medicine remedies contain
mercury and some spiritual and religious
traditions use it in their practices
that's interesting where can I learn
more about all this I know there's a lot
of information on the internet but some
things are difficult to read and
sometimes I don't know who to believe
you're absolutely right
you need good reliable information that
was written for someone your age this
video is part of the National Library of
medicines environmental health student
portal the portal has a section on the
effects of mercury on human health you
can also learn there about other
chemicals in the environment and about
environmental health Wow I'll definitely
check them out thank you you are very
welcome now let's get you back home mom
hurry there's a TV character in our
living room be there in a second where
is this TV character mom she was just
here sure she was just finish up your
sushi
this short film was brought to you by
the environmental health student portal
of the division of specialized
information services at the US National
Library of Medicine visit us online at
these great websites
you